[موسيقى]
انا سفينه الصحراء جمل جمل
وبجسمي ادخر الماء جانا الجمل احتمل الظما
وقسوته جمل جمل دون ما شق دون عناء جامل
جمل انا الجمل انا الجمل جمل هذا خفي يا
اطفال يحملني بين الكسبان بين الكسبان
بينما فازت ورمال لا اشعر اني عطشان لا لا
لا
هذا خبي يا اطفال يحملني بين الكثبان بين
الكسبان بينما فازت ورماد لا اشعر اني
عطشان انا الجمل انا الجمل جمل جمل
الجمال الان الجمل جمل جمل انا الجمل انا
الجمل انا الجمل انا الجمل انا الجمل
اتميز ايضا بسنامي وعيون ضخمه ورموش ضخمه
ورموش بهدوء احياء ايامي وبتلك الصحراء
اعيش لتلك الصحراء
تتميز ايضا بسناني وعيون ضخمه ورموش ضخمه
ورموش بهدوء احياء ايامي وبتلك الصحراء
اعيش
جدل انا ساكن في الصحراء جمل جمل وادي
جسمي ادخر الماء جامل جمل احتمل الظما
وقسوتهم ياما الجمل دون مشقه دون عناء جمل
جمل انا الجمل انا الجمل جمل
وبيسر امشي واسير في تلك الاجواء صبور جدا
صبور وقوي احمل امتعه اياما امشي وشهور
هيا من وشهور وبيسر امشي واسير في تلك
الاجواء صبور
وقوي احمل انتادا اياما امشي والشهود انا
الجمل انا الجمل جمل جمل امل جمل انا
الجمل جمل جمل انا الجمل انا الجمل انا
الجمل انا الجمل انا الجمل جمل